let z1 and z2 be two distinct complex
numbers and let z equal and they say
it's one minus t times z1 plus t times
e2 for some real number with t being
between zero and one and they see if the
argument w denotes the principal
argument of a non-zero complex number w
then and we know the argument is the
angle of kind of the position vector
specifying the complex number of the
complex plane and the real
and the real axis let me just draw that
so if we do an argan diagram this is the
imaginary axis
and this is the real axis if this is our
complex number if that is z
its argument the argument of z is going
to be this angle right over here so phi
is equal to
the argument the argument of z that's
all they're telling us in the second
part now let's go through each of these
and see are true and just to be clear
this is one of those problems where more
than one of these choices might be
correct so let's see if they're true
so let's first figure out what the
magnitude of z minus z1 is
so the magnitude of z minus z1 is going
to be the magnitude of so let me write
this is going to be the magnitude of
let's do the z part first let me write
in the same colors
so if i would just focus on the z first
z is this thing up here and let me
distribute the z1 so it's z1
one minus t z one
minus t z one
and then plus t z two
plus t
z two and from that we wanna subtract z
one
so from that we to subtract z1 so minus
z1
and that and that cancel out
that and that cancel out
and let's see we have we can factor out
a t over here so this is going to be
equal to
the magnitude of let's factor out a t
times z2 minus z1
z2 minus
minus z1 so that is the magnitude of z
minus z1 this first term over here let's
figure out the magnitude of z minus z2
the magnitude of z
minus i'm going to color code it z minus
z2
is equal to the magnitude well z is just
this thing up here
let me just write it out so it is
one minus t
times z1
plus t times z2 that's z and from that
we want to subtract z2 so minus
minus z2 so what can we do over here we
can take a
we can take a t
minus 1 out from here we can factor out
the z2 out of these two terms so this is
going to be equal to the magnitude of
1 minus t
times z1
1 minus t times z1
that's this term right over here
plus let me do it in another color plus
t minus 1
plus
t
minus 1
times z2
times z2 the magnitude of th this part
over here is this thing over there now
let's see what happens when we add this
thing to this thing that's what choice a
is doing we're adding this thing to this
thing let's see if we can simplify it
so this becomes
this becomes the absolute value or the
magnitude of t times z2
minus z1
plus
i'll do the whole thing here in magenta
plus this thing over here
and this thing over here actually before
i even write it out how can we simplify
that we'll have a 1 minus t and a t
minus 1. i'll just write it out here but
i'm going to change it up a little bit
so this is equal to the magnitude of
minus t
1 minus t times z1
and so that i have a 1 minus t here i'm
just going to put a negative out front
so minus
1 minus t i just swap them negative 1
minus t is the same thing as positive t
minus 1
z 2
and then this thing over here since i
have the 1 minus t out there this
becomes the magnitude of i'm just
factoring out the 1 minus t 1 minus t
times
z1 minus
z2
z1
minus z2 so we have this thing
let me copy and paste it
so copy and paste
we have this thing plus this thing this
is what this expression a has simplified
to now let's see if we can simplify that
even more
let's see if we can simplify it even
more so t is just a scalar t is just a
scalar and t is between 0 and 1 they
told us that over here t is between 0
and 1.
so this is positive this right here is a
positive value and then this right here
is also going to be
this right here is also going to be a
positive value t is greater than 0 and
it is less than 1. so this is also going
to be a positive value and these are
just scalars so this is going to be the
same thing these are just scaling the
magnitude so this is going to be the
same thing these are positive values so
this is going to be t
times the absolute value i actually let
me not skip a step this is going to be
the same thing as the absolute value of
t
times the absolute value of z 2 minus z1
because this is just scaling it
plus
the absolute value
of 1 minus t
plus the absolute value of 1 minus t
times the absolute value of z1 minus z2
now let me be clear the absolute value
of z1 minus z2 is going to be equal to
the absolute value of z2 minus z1 these
vectors are just pointing in different
directions or these complex numbers one
is just the negative of the other but
their absolute values or their
magnitudes are going to be the same so
let me write z2 minus z1 the absolute
value of z2 minus z1 there and the
reason why i'm doing it is so i get the
same thing here and i can factor it out
so the absolute value of z2 minus z1
it's the same thing as the absolute
value of z1 minus z2 because we're not
it's just going in the other direction
now what can we do here
well the absolute value of t remember t
is positive so this is just this is just
going to be equal to t
the absolute value of 1 minus t once
again that's positive so that's just
going to be 1 minus t so we can factor
we can factor this business out so we're
going to get t
plus 1 minus
plus 1 minus t
times the absolute value times the
absolute value of z2 minus z1 z2 minus
z1 now the t's cancel out here we just
got a 1 out front so this is just equal
to the absolute value of z2
minus z1 so we see that choice a does
work this plus this does indeed equal
that i'm going to leave you there and in
the next video we're going to try out
some of these other possibilities to see
if they might also be true